in the world of stills you'll hear a lot
of sales trainers say some will some was
so what next meaning like don't worry
about it if they said no move on to the
next person here it's going to be okay
I'm here to tell you that this week you
could you could potentially meet
somebody that could totally change the
face your business and you tend to say
some will some want so what next and
that's it no you can't do that and
explain to you why my business is where
it's not because of me seizing those
certain moments like I sit and I think
about my business and I can think off
the top of my hand let you say ten
meetings that I had that if I it was
this close for me to say nothing's going
to come out of this and I pushed a
little bit more that led to I can truly
tell you 15 million dollars one business
is fifteen million dollars one contact I
was at an event in LAX 2000 2001 look
how many years ago this is I met this
gentleman sharpest guy on stage speaking
charming charismatic beard sexy hip cool
beautiful wife I'm like oh my gosh I'm
22 and I approached him and I say I want
to talk to you can I take you out of
know you know all this stuff happier
with so many things of he in action I
met so I kept pushing pushing pushing
finally we met and I knew I had this one
opportunity and we sat down and we spoke
and I said look I want you to know
something he says what's that I said
look I want to do business with you I
want us to be together he told me he's
got money he's got here every single
thing financially in place like
insurance annuities investments Ratana
mutual funds what was it nothing could
happen because he had the best advisors
finance that I'm going to befriend him
and I'm going to figure out a way what
we can do with this relationship
we ended up become a best friend his son
was in prison I went to prison and got
my background check all the stuff and I
spent a lot of time with this guy son in
prison I came back after prison a month
two months later he gave me his entire
rolodex 600 of his context that I can
use his name with after those 600 names
he gave me one of the names that came
through led to 15 million dollars of
business
I'm going to probably saying the smaller
number is probably bigger than others
525 million dollars but 15 to 25 million
dollars one contact what if I didn't
follow up with that what if I didn't do
anything what if I just said some will
someone so what's next I would have lost
a lot of money and you could as well so
this week everybody your meeting with
don't be the typical sales of that
system will somewhat so what next
maximize the relationships and the
people you meet with this week ask for
referrals ask who they know get deeper
ask a few more question have a solid
relationship here they're not listen to
them don't just sit and go like this and
go fall your script listen to what
they're saying go deeper capture their
heart move them and then all of a sudden
go deeper next thing you know Decker
leading to you 15 years from now saying
15 years ago I watched a video on value
1000 what Pat talked about don't follow
the philosophy assemble somewhat so what
next
I met a contact that we can because of
that contact I'm now worth seventy three
million dollars because I didn't let
that contact go without me maximize it
that potential make this week challenge
[Music]
you